انه اجيني ثلاث مسلسلات وفي غيره ما عم
يشتغل وبيقولوا انه كيف تجرقي او بتقدري
اعصابك تقول لا قيمه لا توازي قيمه اه
لقيتهم مش بمستوى سنه الماضي ملف سري
قدمني كما يجب ان اقدم كشخصيه وفي شروط
اخرى انتاجيه وين نحط اسمك او مصرياتك
فاخذت قرار لا لثلاثه مسلسلات وماني
ندمانه وعم بعمل اذاعه
الشعب المصري كثير بحب الاذاعه هلا
بتشوفيهم قاعدين عم بتسمعوا اللي جايين
السواقين بالسياره بالعربيه اذا يجب ان
تصلي الى موقع ما والى مكان ما ان تعرفي
ان تقولي لا لانها توازي النعم وربما افضل
سمر ومادلين
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
بس برافو عليك برافو برافو انه برافو
مادلين انت قلتي رفضتي ثلاث ادوار بتدوري
على ايه دلوقتي انت وصلتي للمرحله دي ايه
اللي بتبصي عليه الدور ولا الكاتب ولا
الموضوع ولا حجمه ولا ان هو يتعرض في
رمضان
هي توليفه على بعض يعني لازم اعرف دوري مش
ضروري يكون هو دور البطوله يعني انا في
ملف سري كنت مع نجوم كبار مثل حبيبي هاني
سلامه ولكن قدمت كما يجب ان تقدم هذه
الشخصيه كتابه المخرج الانتاج
المصاري قديش يندفع لك اسمك وين حينزل هي
توليفي كامله مع مين عم تشتغلي يعني انا
اذا في ممثل حيتعبني ممكن ارفض يعني بعد
وصلت لمرحله انه والله لا بشتغل فيه هيدي
لكن في ممثلات ما بتفرق معهم بشتغلوا
بشتغلوا اي شيء شغل انا ما بعتبر التمثيل
شغل مازلت رغم 35 36 سنه مازلت بحس اني
بستمتع واني هاويه واني لازم اروح انبسط
[موسيقى]
اكيد احنا معكم قاعدين بالجلسه قاعدين
بالجلسه احنا معكم ومحضرين كمان فوازير بس
عايزين نسال كمان مادلين احنا اول مره على
كل حال بنسمعك باللهجه اللبنانيه خلص احنا
نسينا مادلين عايش بمصر ولهجه المصريه كل
الوقت سامعينها هاي اول مره هيك من فتره
بنسمع العربيه وام بي سي اكيد مادلين
اليوم قد ايه مصر وانت عشتي في مصر هي
بوابه فعلا
للنجوميه خصوصا في عالم التمثيل امام زحمه
الاعمال الدراميه الكثيره في عالمنا اليوم
العربي
ليكي انا واقعيه ورح اقول الحقيقه في
دراما عظيمه عم تطلع علينا صار لها 10
سنين يلي هي الدراما اللبنانيه وفيها
خليجي وفيها احيانا نسول في احيانا مصري
وفي دراما ثاني عم تنعمل تاريخيه كانت
سابقا واصبحت دراما هلا بس السوريه لكن
طبعا الظروف الامنيه شوي اخرتها وفي دراما
الخليجيه دراما شابه لكن شابه قويه جدا
لكن رغم كل هذه الدراما المتواجده على
الساحه الفنيه وبدون مملقه التخرج
من مصر يعني مصر مثل ما تقولي بتعطيك
الشهاده الماجستير يعني انا ممكن انجح
بعدد من هذه الدرامات واتواجد وممكن كثير
في بعض اللبنانيات اشتغلوا بس لبناني
وانعرفوا بس ما ينعرفوا على الصعيد الكبير
الا من خلال هوليود الشرق عن جد مصر
هوليود الشرق مش هيك مش هيك رايك سمر
بالضبط
كانت من اول ما بدات السينما اللي كانت
دايما فيها كل الجنسيات العربيه يعني احنا
لدرجه ان احنا يعني كتير من الجمهور
المصري ما يعرفوش ان في فنانين اصولهم
عربيه من كتر ما كنا كلنا حاجه واحده يعني
في هنقول نكته على الخبريه ههه فانا
بالمسلسل مع استاذ عادل امام كان المفروض
في جمله انه حبيب قلبي ما بعرف شو بس هيك
بلبنان يعني
الجمهور المصري بالشارع اللي يا سلام
البنت دي فظيعه ده بتقول لبناني كده
[ضحك]
بس الناس في الشارع عرفتني مصريه انا
البنت بتاعت ايلات
انت بقيتي مصريه على الاصول يعني وحتى
الاجواء كلها مصريه يعني من اللبس والزينه
واحنا مش رح نطول عليكم لانه اذن من شوي
حنتركهم على موعد الافطار وهاي الجلسه
الحلوه على النيل ويا بختكم انتم